je sais pas si c'est l'approche des
vacances mais ce soir vous allez nous
donner l'envie de voyager avec toujours
un pied dans les Yvelines ça c'est ça
c'est premier et vous n'en nous emmener
d'abord à la rencontre d'un couple
d'yvinois tout à fait oui oui c'est la
proche des vacances vous avez
complètement deviné donc un pied dans
les Yvelines oui parce qu'ils sont de la
Vallée de Chevreuse sont Valérie et
Bertrand de Gruson qui sont en fait des
amoureux de la Grèce et qui proposent
des voyages un peu hors norme à moto
avec un parcours un circuit et des
adresses enfin je vais vous expliquer ça
donc eux c'est l'historique de ce cette
histoire de cette aventure c'est qu'il
reste ça ressemble trois passions déjà
la passion de la moto pour Bertrand
Valérie qui était passagère a fini par
elle-même attraper le virus et passer
son permis la passion de la Grèce où il
passe leurs vacances depuis plus de 10
ans qu'ils connaissent comme leurs
poches et puis leur passion commune se
couple s'aiment et heureux de faire
quelque chose ensemble qui les amuse
donc à force d'aller en Grèce et de
connaître plein de choses leurs amis
leur demander toujours des adresses des
bons plans etc ils sont dit mais
pourquoi pas en faire carrément une
activité en plus de leur job actuel donc
qui sont associés tous les deux et ils
sont maintenant voyageistes
imaginez-vous mais alors leur
propositions sont un peu particulières
c'est à dire que ce qu'il existe déjà
c'est soit des voyages à moto de
proximité ou alors des voyages à moto à
l'autre bout du monde souvent sur des
des pistes à nos béquistes enfin des
endroits très très loin eux c'est un peu
un compromis entre les deux c'est à dire
que vous arrivez à Athènes vous louez
ils sont avec vous il y a une formule
tout compris c'est un groupe vous êtes 6
à 8 motos et il vous guide du début à la
fin vous louez donc là il voulut la moto
pardon j'ai du mal et c'est une BMW
c'est toujours pourquoi parce que
sécurité confort c'est comme ça il y a
quand même de la route faut savoir que
la graisse 80% de relief donc ça monte
ça descend c'est pas il y a pas de pic
de vitesse on respecte la nature on en
profite on est au plus près de la nature
c'est magnifique voilà mère montagne on
peut s'arrêter c'est souple ils
connaissent des bons petits restos enfin
il vous donne les clés pour profiter de
l'authenticité du pays hors des sentiers
battus ces voyages là en groupe c'est
hors saison c'est avant l'été et après
l'été là où la Grèce est la moins
envahit par les touristes après il y a
une formule ou il ne vous accompagne pas
vous pouvez être à deux tout seul ou
avec des copains et là vous avez le
parcours les guides et tout ça mais ils
ne sont pas avec vous et une autre
conseil ah ben complètement vous avez
vraiment les clés pour souvent quand on
voit des choses très authentiques des
petits restent tout ça on n'ose pas trop
parce qu'on sait pas comment se
comporter là où vous êtes sûr d'être
bien accueilli ils connaissent les gens
et les Grecs vous attendent avec un
grand bonheur et ou après il y a encore
une formule
vous ne faites que louer la moto et
parce que c'est pas évident et après et
un jour bientôt il y aura une autre
encore formule où vous partirez de
France avec votre propre moto et vous
mettrez eux c'est ce qui depuis 5 ans il
se donne 10 jours pour atteindre la
Grèce en passant par l'ouzbé les Balkans
enfin bref une véritable aventure qui
vont bientôt nous faire partager en
Suisse de celle-là voilà alors toujours
en lien avec la graisse une versaillaise
qui a créé un objet qui a retenu votre
attention avec complètement parce que
c'est bien utile et en plus c'est joli
elle s'appelle Séverine Saki elle aussi
passe ses vacances en Grèce dans sa
famille depuis très longtemps et elle
remarque que elle est souvent importunée
par les guêpes quand on déjeune dehors
ou qu'on dîne dehors bref ça fait partie
du truc donc elle a essayé des méthodes
qui n'ont pas très très bien marché le
marc de café brûlé ça sent pas très bon
on est enfumé la raquette électrique
c'est un peu moche la bouteille de sirop
plein de cadavre de guêpes ça donne
envie de vomir aussi ces techniques
c'est vrai que ça marche pas vous allez
en connaître une nouvelle voilà et un
jour par hasard dans un hôtel en Grèce
elle a vu une petite cabane à guêpes
justement c'est que ce truc et en fait
je me suis dit mais je vais faire la
même chose peut-être un peu plus
sophistiqué donc avec un menuisier local
elle a étudié le problème elle a trouvé
un système donc c'est c'est un objet qui
est très joli qui est design dans lequel
vous mettez de la protéine parce que la
guêpe pour nourrir ses larves elle veut
des protéines et comme ça vous êtes sûr
de pas attirer les abeilles aussi parce
que c'est grâce à cet appât là qu'on
attrape pas les abeilles parce que faut
quand même faire attention aux aber
aussi donc la guêpe avec ses petites
pattes elles montent la petite marche
elle rentre dans le petit tube et boum
elle trouve son repas elle est ravi par
contre elle veut pas repartir toute
seule et vous vous êtes tranquille vous
déjeunez en paix parce que comme je dis
bien souvent il y a pas que Stéphane
Eicher qui a envie de déjeuner en paix
alors voilà et donc elle a trouvé donc
le concept là ça marche très bien il y a
deux restaurants à Versailles qui ont
cette piège à Gap qui appelle le
guet-apens et
la Guinguette et le chat qui prise et
alors il faut savoir aussi que c'est un
objet qui est fait en bois de de je ne
sais plus pas Douglas voilà bois
certifié machin tout ce qu'il faut
fabrication solidaire parce que cette
année ça te l'a est très près de
Cergy-Pontoise qui fabrique donc déjà
des gens qui sont en insertion
professionnelle voilà il y a un projet
en plus
et donc c'est une fois que vous avez
fini votre déjeuner votre pas vous
pouvez libérer les guêpes elle sortiront
à leur rythme sans violence et la
biodiversité est respectée c'est
inoffensif pour les insectes vous vous
êtes bien tranquille et
tout va bien vous nous mettez des
chansons dans la tête en tout cas c'est
en train de chanter Stéphane et Cher en
région Veronique alors pour terminer je
le disais vous présenter avec brio cette
émission
very villenoise personne qui mette en
lumière les les personnalités du
département alors l'un de vos derniers
numéros vous avez vous êtes allés à la
rencontre du jardinier chef du grand
parc de Versailles du domaine national
de tri-annonce bien sûr à l'embarathon
notre ami fidèle qui à chaque fois qu'il
sort un livre nous reçoit gentiment donc
là c'est le livre de la rose on était en
son jardin et nous a raconté il nous a
pas le seul livre plein d'anecdotes
d'historique etc et du coup c'est bien
qu'on en parle parce que j'ai oublié de
dire un truc dans ce VIP je vous le dis
à vous si ça vous intéresse le jour où
planterait un rosier dans le trou avant
de planter le rosier mettez une peau de
banane
pourquoi je ne sais pas
aveuglément j'ai entièrement confiance
en ses talents de jardinier donc à
retrouver dès à présent sur TV 78.com
sur notre site internet en intégralité
on a vu quelques-unes des images merci
Véronique on se dit à mardi prochain